[Music]
so there's a lot of you know Rotten
Tomatoes celebrating our 25th birthday
this year and I'm here with Corey who's
the co-founder of cryptozoic and you
helped come up with this card game that
we have to celebrate our big day tell me
how this all came to pass you know we
had the opportunity to work with a
Fandango and Rotten Tomatoes to try and
make a game that celebrated everything
that's really great about the Rotten
Tomatoes experience and so we were lucky
enough to find a game designer that had
just this amazing design and you know
the important thing when we make games
out of beloved properties is that what
we call top down design which means if I
play this game I need to feel like I'm
really experiencing Rotten Tomatoes so
when it came to the Rotten Tomatoes
party game the big question became well
how do you make a game that really makes
it feel like well what is it what is a
game for Rotten Tomatoes we already know
we care about movies and we debate the
Tomato Meter there's even a podcast
about it and so how do you get together
with your buddies well you do the card
game so tell me exactly how it does work
so this is what's so brilliant about
this game is that anyone can learn to
play it in three easy steps well I'm not
just anyone I'm really really kind of
dumb so let's let's let's put that
theory to the test the way it works is
each of these cards has a movie that
shows the Rotten Tomato score uh it
shows you the fan score and what happens
at the beginning is you get several cars
that you lay out you put them in uh
order of lowest Rotten Tomato score to
highest and there's going to be a gap in
there so you'll see as an example we
have here uh Legally Blonde with a 70
Inception with an 87 and a quiet place
for the 96 so that's your lineup and
then what's going to happen is their
players are going to take turns one
player is going to ask the other player
I pull out the card and they're gonna
say Back to the Future and your job is
to tell them where in this lineup Back
to the Future goes is it more than 87 so
it goes between Inception and a quiet
place at 96 is it a hundred percent if
you had to take your guess would you say
it was better or worse than Legally
Blonde better or worse than Inception or
better and worse than quiet place okay
according to the Tomato Meter if the
quiet place that 96 I'm going to say
that it's somewhere between Legally
Blonde and a quiet place yes you're
absolutely right the way the game works
is you're going to continue to do that
uh go around taking turns and then the
first person to get 10 movies actually
wins the game super simple super easy to
play there's also wild cards that have
things like they'll read the name of the
movie and everyone gets a chance try and
guess which cast member is in it there's
ones that talk about when it's came out
so really fun wild cards that pop up
that challenge different parts of your
movie uh trivia knowledge and that's the
really big thing for this game movie
trivia games for me like I remember
trying to get the Star Wars Trivial
Pursuit when I was a kid I'm like oh I
love Star Wars I was really good at that
in college I couldn't answer one
question in that whole game that's the
problem with movie trivia is so specific
so they can make enough questions that
it just locks out everyone who wants to
play how the hell the name of the
Stormtrooper that first appeared are you
kidding me and so you are preaching to
the choir right now so what's great
about Rotten Tomatoes is I can be a
hardcore movie fan and I can still have
this game be hyper accessible because I
think I know which movies was better
than this one or which one was worse
than that one and the debate about the
Tomato score is such a fun party
experience that it makes the whole
everything about this game feels so much
fun I mean that's what you want when
you're at a party you don't necessarily
want to go over rules for 30 minutes you
just want an easy game you can play so
on a scale of like Go Fish to Gin Rummy
the Rotten Tomatoes the card game is way
more fun than either one of those
exactly you can learn to play from
reading the back of the box that's how
quick it is and if you love movies you
don't have to know everything about
movies you just have an opinion about
movies and you're gonna love playing
this game people can pick this up just
about anywhere games are sold yeah it's
actually Barnes and Noble Target uh from
the online store it's going to be
everywhere uh you know this is the kind
of game I think that anyone who loves
movies and loves a quick to learn quick
to you know jump into game is going to
absolutely adore and since I have the
microphone with this logo I just get to
keep this one for free yes absolutely
they're going to take it from me as soon
as we cut foreign
[Music]